strike first strike hard no
mercy cobra kai has returned and i'm
sure
whoever's watching this you probably
already finished the season
well we're starting it today the goal is
to get uploads up on youtube
at least every other day until we're
done with the season make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified
when our next cobra kai reaction is up
and while you're at it if you go ahead
hit the like button it helps out the
algorithm and this is youtube we
obviously can't show the whole thing
this qualifies as reaction highlights
full length reaction watch as long as we
can sync up with the time code we'll be
over at our patreon page
we're over there recover so many shows
we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
along included
include it included it's the word
included shows like supernatural
doctor who attack on titan avatar the
last airbender
demon slayer psych a whole bunch of
television
shows galore yay i want to thank
everyone who's been pledged to our
patreon page and everyone who is new to
our patreon thank you for joining let's
swing it to action people
turning to defend his title from cobra
car karate
oh marquee gonna play a fantasy we're
watching right now right this is
his lucid dream before fantasy yeah
look at how suave that hair looks
oh homeboy's been training yeah homeboy
moves
better dang
yeah it was two weeks ago today at west
valley high
where what can only be described as an
all-out
sending shockwave we got enough to worry
about these days
now i gotta worry about karate games
earlier today students organized a
peaceful gathering
does it hurt
this is johnny it's probably getting
piss drunk right yeah do i need to call
the cops
i don't know do you police are still
looking for robbie ran away
after kicking oh fellow
that makes sense keane has since been
expelled
he ran away all education
hey you're watching that it was my
criminal son on tv
that was slim reliving trauma you want
to see the news check the phone
i don't have a phone he threw it in the
beach
you smell like a piece of dog [ __ ] took
a dump a piece of
dog [ __ ] took a dump people want to
watch the game they don't give a [ __ ]
about no weather reports
oh oh you just said the worst thing no
karate is gonna break out at the bar
here you go homie
that's my bad wow johnny did not oh
never mind okay
he's gonna smash their faces in through
these car windows
what's wrong with that
jesus
dude johnny come on johnny
oh buddy hell yeah i'm going to tell the
school board how incompetent they are
this fake spell the girl who started the
whole thing no that [ __ ] would be
insulting
[Music]
jesus dealership is a ghost town
it's not that bad yes it is you're never
there you wouldn't know
turns out kicking the competition isn't
a cute tagline when your karate student
literally kicks the competition over a
and railing promise i'm gonna find a way
to get us out okay come on
more karate that's the answer
everyone at the school board cares about
the safety of our students where the
hell were the teachers
where are
i don't think chris is going to give a
[ __ ] about that we have a new initiative
called hugs
not hits tell me how it's appropriate
that our daughter got suspended while
some dinosaur freddy krueger nearly tore
her face
oh damn i don't get ohio mighty larusso
you're the one who taught these kids
that my edgy crap oh
you reap what you saw oh there are no
bad students only bad
teachers oh all the parents are gonna
start taking karate
settle the scores themselves hey blondie
look at that
wow holy [ __ ] applebee's guy
ha ha ha full bees guy bobby made a
mistake should mean his life is over
tell that to the kitty killed killed oh
did something happen to miguel but after
two weeks in a coma
coma using wins hell no miguel's gonna
come out stronger and faster
he's going to remember a bunch of skills
he didn't know he's just building that
muscle right now
yep god god
torey's going to die this season
let the healing begin one thin sweater
at a time
freshman year can be kind of scary so if
anybody gives you any trouble just come
to me
i'm the guy who left the bedroom
[Music]
mean
[Laughter]
they don't need security
i'm a warrior now everything all right
here this is a cool way to handle
[Laughter]
recaps
i go to paris for one summer the losers
are running the school i feel a little
nicer
half the kids
y'all should be terrified yeah
why do you laugh with people who are
brawling
look at the weirdo totally capable of
kicking an ass
there captain marvel oh
poor sam go wake up miguel hey boss uh
mrs boss
i got something on my computer you gotta
see and don't worry it's not porno this
time
it's not part of this time are your
channels right
that's the one thing i know it's
inventory i worked at fat styles all
summer inventory is everything oh fat
sounds good
you're actually missing a 93 dodge
caravan robbie
miguel he's just got a hospital bed in
the back of a minivan
it's inconspicuous exactly
he's caught between worlds he's lived a
lifetime in this coma
damn their sound effects are apart
[Music]
not this year oh no
they didn't want to see you johnny can't
you uh you know
break the rules johnny
johnny only family doctors and patients
in the icu
oh i love when characters get doctor's
outfits so easily absolutely
no one questions them afterwards
[Music]
you're gonna have to do is crash your
car into the van
uh smart kid
he must have remembered we track all the
trade-ins damn he's
too good of an employee
[Music]
hey doc i got this ugh
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude you're never going to be allowed
back at this hospital
[Music]
i had a little walter white moment there
smart
oh my smart
oh they got a cgi face
miyagi they gotta bring him in show up
on the imperial ship with his green
lightsaber and just mess everyone up
dad why aren't you in school it's
traumatizing
i just had to get out of there i came
here
well in and out and then here
los angeles references it's in other
parts of the america too
[Music]
yeah yeah different when you're a girl i
mean even if you win
you're not cool or tough i think you're
crazy
yeah because you are
duh all this started before you were
even born
hmm it's the inventor of karate's fault
it's not for me and johnny there
wouldn't have been a fight in the first
place the sins of the father
but there's one thing i do know for sure
and that's
can't run away from your problems i wish
you could i can't run away from mine
i think that's the theme of the season
uh oh
oh oh collab found blood on his urine
oh that no biggie i got a fight last
night
it's a little uh
you should have led with all this yeah
you didn't have to
make yourself bleed dude you would have
been a-okay you're bleeding internally
all right
you're learning so fast getting so
strong but i failed you
i'm so sorry
don't worry he's learning in the coma
he's learning in the coma he's gonna
come back
even more of a skilled martial artist
oh that's cool he's going to win the
fight
oh this is what he loves
never surrender i know you can't excuse
me
only family is allowed in here yeah
let's just leave it
i'm just trying to motivate this kid out
of a coma come on twitch for me miguel
twitch just a little twitch
just a little twitch oh i'm gonna get
the twitch
gonna get the twitch where's the twitch
chat come on what's the twitch
johnny oh he doesn't know
loved if crease is still here just
smoking a cigarette
standing in front of the light we're
waiting for someone to walk in
we're closed hell yeah where's johnny
he's not here right now but he'll be
back
but i don't really blame robbie because
you know what they say
there's no such thing as a bad step
that's that i said earlier oh you dude
you're just like crease
you see the miyagi name dragged through
the mind i wish i could see the look on
the little bastard oh you [ __ ]
that little bastard kicked your head
damn straight and honked your nose
you're lucky he taught me true karate
that's why i'm not gonna fight you
yeah oh but this has to end with him
fighting crease
not while i'm away no no no no
no no you know where to find me
his teeth are so white he does have a
very cool bad guy smile
look they're still there they're still
looking waiting for her to come back
i've had no one to look at and snicker
all this time
karate them yeah you want to say
something
say it to my face
that's what i thought what if they
weren't talking about her
we gotta join karate i saw your old
sensation look i don't want to get into
it right now all right i got a headache
i need some sleep where's johnny have a
new york accent i'm trying to find him
on my own
they're gonna
oh buddy cops
look i don't want to be here any more
than you this is l.a right now
oh she cut his hair
he doesn't have anyone to help him oh
that is oh robbie what'd you do to
yourself
you went you looked you went all lloyd
so much younger oh my god
he does look like lord
poor miguel he's been fighting this
fight for two weeks
come on twitch twitch miguel gasp for
life
come on to the twitch
boom
could you do it again but oh
yeah rest in peace
ah god did i miss this show
it's so nice to be back all right so we
don't need to get bogged down in
predictions all the episodes are
available now i do wonder if
they restructured their season a little
bit different because it's all available
at once now
you know as opposed to week to week
either way i'm just excited to be back
in this world
it's like it's so i i personally prefer
the series over the movies
i don't know how much of a complaint of
how people might not like me saying that
but i personally
think the series are an improvement upon
the movies it's like there's the karate
kid one
and then the series and the other two
movies i'm like
all right going off of here you know i
like the themes that we're setting up
of you know you can't run away from your
problems like that's kind of where
everyone's at right now everyone's kind
of in this form of escapism
especially mcgill especially miguel man
he's faking that
running away from his problems with a
coma
then you got sam as well who has to
learn to embrace the pain
uh as she keeps going i like that type
of overcoming trauma because
that's kind of the thing with with
trauma sometimes you sort of have to
embrace it you know especially depending
on the circumstance i appreciate the
sort of psychological element they've
taken on each one of these characters at
this at this starting off point
daniel i this felt a little bit more
like it was daniel's like this show
often feels like it's johnny show and
daniel's the main supporting character
and this episode felt particularly like
his daniel larusso's episode more than
it was johnny lawrence's episode so i
thought for
setting off on your season three i
thought that was an interesting
take in some ways i think it might just
be an equal 50 50 split but i'm excited
at the fact that they're going to be
working together you know i don't know
how long that's going to last
or if it'll come apart and then maybe
come back together at some point over
the season because there's so many
things that can get in the way of them
but yeah just like the
promise that finally here on season
three they will
team up and hopefully at least separate
this duo from crease and hopefully take
the fight to crease you know like that a
makes tons and tons of sense and b like
gets me super excited especially after
like the little glimpses we've had in
seasons prior where you can see that
johnny and danny could almost be friends
and like i'm hoping that maybe through
this healing experience that can happen
well yeah i mean they've taken this
interesting approach of you know going
back to that old phrase or the
the sins of our father like that's you
know how does that go
something about the father bunch of
dicks and then the sons and the six
fathers
i'm kind of paraphrasing here just a
little bit but i think that's what the
bible said
um but yeah but taking that approach
it's just so fascinating to think about
where this season started off with this
series of daniel's in a good place
johnny's in a
really hard spot and he still is in a
hard spot but how the daniel larusso
name is so beloved you know like west
valley high la russo's automobile
company
and then you start off this episode
everyone's blaming larussa yeah you know
it's like that's
this is johnny lawrence's kid who
everyone hates right now
ravi but they all know him as the
protege of daniel larusso and the miyagi
dojo and all that so all the
hatred and especially the image of sam
all the hatred is going towards dana
lusso so their reputation is tarnished
no one even seemed to bring up cobra kai
in that you know pa meeting that they
were having or the or the assembly
meeting that they were having
that's a cool way to to to make them
back to being the underdog
of daniel larusso of they have some
repairing to do towards their image
and more importantly than that they
don't even seem that self-absorbed with
it they just really care about finding
robbie and helping him
fascinating to see what direction they
take it with robbie and i'm i'm like
i think miguel is going to go down this
like i said i don't want to get too
bogged down in predictions but i feel
like miguel is going to be going down a
path of some type of redemption since he
went all dark miguel last season
robbie is going to be going down the
redemption path as well but now i'm like
whose side am i going to be on by the
end of this because i feel like they're
both going to be pretty good guys by the
end of the season
but yeah they both have like such a feud
driven between them and i feel like
that's part of the gravity that drives a
lot of the most fascinating and touching
parts of the show because danny and
johnny are both like that as well and i
feel like too
because season two kind of brought this
idea that you know danny's
struggling to find his own voice as
teacher as sensei and like you said you
know like there are no bad students and
then chris
echoes that right at him yeah so i feel
like you know we've watched johnny in a
lot of ways
grow into a teacher more and i feel like
there's also that probably for
danny this season but just as like a
place setter episode you know i like
at least they kind of acknowledge from
the parents perspective like
why isn't anyone able to mitigate these
kids we're all fighting each other
because you know i feel like it is a
meme of the show where of like if
anybody ever called the cops
a lot of stuff would be different you
know what the this intro
kind of reminded me of you know how
there was avengers end game or the
infinity war end game movies that had
like such
heaviness when dealing with the snap and
then you cut to far from home with
spider-man and it's kind of making
fun of you love the snap and like the
kind of funny circumstances that could
have arisen from that yeah
and that's kind of what i like in this
too of how
the last season ended on this like crazy
high school karate
dark breakout fight it was like so epic
and so bleak and then you cut to here
and it's just like they're poking fun at
how ridiculous
it is also you know yeah you just kind
of go with the heightened reality of
this world of yeah
these high schools being overtaken by
karate there's a karate war happening
like i think that was so funny the
teachers can't break why did the
teachers come in and i mean like those
are real rules i think like you know
there are rules about you can't
like physically intervene and stuff and
so like you know
even though this is much more heightened
i do appreciate them bringing things
like that in and even little notes like
when he's talking to sam in the backyard
and she's like look for a girl
when you win a fight like that you don't
get to reap the rewards the same way
you do if you're a guy or whatever you
know people just kind of shun you and
think of you as crazy and then she was
even nicknamed
captain marvel by dimitri here right
yeah everyone's favorite
i i stood out to him and they said
captain marvel i'm like
you know captain marvel on the internet
that real artist is not the most loved
yeah with your if you're
better
yeah but i bet that was an intentional
choice yeah
i bet it was they're sure come on guys
you know what you
know it they didn't do the lab coat
trope that i know they interested
inverted
expectations clever pull on their end i
actually
really liked this whole thing like
there's something kind of funny to me
about the fact that miguel has been
living this one
fight scene in his head keeps losing you
know it's ended
that that fight that he has is a
parallel to the fight that he lost with
robbie in a certain way i mean even
though he didn't lose that fight he was
a cheap shot hit uh he won right yeah he
won he saw mercy and then robbie [ __ ]
pulled a
a cheap shot on him having uh this the
sequence and you know the mom's even
talking like talk to him about the
things that he loves and stuff and then
you know as an audience like we'll talk
about karate
but the family doesn't want to talk
about never having right
here the last thing the family wants to
talk about and then johnny showing up
there
that father figure that mentor showing
on even on the deep subconscious level
being in a coma how much of a heart and
influence and connectivity that johnny
and miguel
have with one another was a beautiful
note because you're watching him lose
and then suddenly he wins when he has
johnny in his corner so i thought that
was a great i i thought this was a
really great episode
and yeah just like instantly a few
minutes in i'm like hi
i missed this [ __ ] i was hoping it's
such a fun show it's like such a fun
show
uh all right guys well what'd you think
of the first episode i guess after all
you guys already done watching the
series
who's your favorite character in
corporate guy we'll have to ask random
questions who's your favorite character
without leaving spoilers down below
subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least let's do
up
tyler hague i saw your recent message
i'm
sorry about the recent symptoms
you're experiencing you know what sorry
this is the way you're starting off the
new year buddy
i know you man i know you you got a
heart of gold you're gonna get better
no matter what happens you're gonna get
better you gotta be like miguel yeah
you gotta just keep fighting through it
keep fighting through it keep that
resilience up and i guarantee you
you will recover and you will get better
i love you man
i hope you had a great christmas i mean
happy new year all things considered so
i just wanted to say that you're in my
thoughts
you're my prayers right now that's not
even necessary because i know you
you're tough and no matter what happens
you're gonna heal and you're gonna get
better
and knowing my luck i'm gonna post this
video and i'm gonna get a message back
you're gonna be like false alarm
that's the way my luck goes it's all
good man either way
keep fighting and get healthy but i love
you dude
so i hope 2021 turns out a better year
for you than 2020 was for all of us
for your life too 2021 you're gonna rock
it this year and you're going to enjoy
them
f out of that ps5 i love you dude
you be safe